things can get pretty serious over at
the scp foundation from world-ending
eldritch beings like the scarlet king to
massive reptiles filled with hate it can
be difficult to find things to smile
about when staring into the face of a
noble horror day after day i don't know
about all of you but i could use a break
from the next snapping sculptures and
old men climbing out of walls so welcome
guys gals and lovers of laughter come on
down and take a seat it's open mic night
here at the scp foundation and we're
hoping to give you a show that won't
make you want to take amnestics welcome
to the scp explained comedy night some
of the funniest anomalies ever contained
by the foundation are lined up backstage
and ready to show you their stuff so
without further ado let's get this show
on the road and find out which scps will
make you bust a gut and which ones will
be taking a bad joke tomato to the head
we've got a whole bucket of these babies
ready to go in the wings and remember
they can reach speeds over 100 miles per
hour so
bring your a-game everybody first up
coming to the stage fresh off of a
morale boosting tour around site 19 you
know him you love him he's the sweetest
silliest slimiest guy around it's
scp-990
the tickle monster just because he can't
say anything funny or anything at all
aside from those adorable little
chirping sounds he makes that doesn't
mean he can't get a good giggle out of
two of you sure some folks out there
might say oh tickling doesn't count but
those people just hate fun he may not be
a comedian in the strictest sense of the
word but you just can't keep a straight
face when this guy comes around you've
gotta break out in the smile just look
at him go slamming all over the place
doing his thing love that for you oh and
there he goes he found a chocolate bar
go ahead buddy you've earned it do you
like prop comedy juggling do you think
it's the funniest thing in the world to
watch your buddy stuff as many
marshmallows as humanly possible into
his mouth and try not to choke then i've
got some great news for you up next
we've got the one the only
scp-2094 that's right folks it's motor
mouth this guy is an extremely
proficient juggler and circus performer
but that's not all he can fit anything
and i do mean anything into his mouth
seriously he's literally capable of
stretching his mouth up to 2 meters in
any direction without feeling any pain
talk about jaw dropping
and inside he's got an extra dimensional
organ made of some seriously stretchy
tissue i heard some of you laugh when i
said extra dimensional organ that's the
spirit watch as he swallows a luxury
sports car that ugly sweater your
grandma got you for christmas that
overstuffed chair your ex-wife left
behind all that and he's still got room
in his mouth for jokes too we've all
heard about the various things this next
guy isn't allowed to do with the
foundation from using anomalies to alter
the outcomes of reality tv shows to
pranking new staff members his antics
are as legendary as the amulet around
his neck that holds his consciousness
and pure essence it's dr jack wright
this immortal trickster has a taste for
mischief even when it gets in the way of
his colleagues important work you've all
been there sometimes a goof is just too
good to go ungoofed so what if it
threatens to destroy the very fabric of
reality or unleash a monster with an
insatiable lust for blood we'll all
learn to laugh about it later dr bright
isn't the best co-worker but he's always
the life of the party and he really
knows how to command the attention of
the room just one thing if he tosses
that amulet at you don't catch it unless
you think complete and total brain death
as your mind and all your memories are
taken over by his sounds like a great
way to end your evening sometimes the
best comedy is the simplest let's throw
it back to the days of america's
funniest home videos when households all
over the country were guffawing at the
site of home movies of people getting
knocked into pools hit in the head with
plastic bats and falling over in a
variety of different ways it might sound
terrible to say but we can all agree
people falling over can be pretty
hilarious but what about a robot falling
over what if that robot was also
convinced that it could destroy you or
anything else it encountered in
hand-to-hand combat pretty ridiculous
right don't worry it's not too good to
be true please give a round of applause
for scp-1370
pesterbot i am robo lord the destructor
ender of all life tremble before me
that's right buddy you tell him careful
there's a mic cord on the ground there
don't and he's down like a turtle
flipped onto its back can someone um
flip pesterbot back over thank you
thanks brian you're my rock give it up
for our sound engineer brian everybody
and for pesterbot of course he's kind of
a one-trick pony but man that trick
never gets old trying so hard to be
intimidating and then bam down like a
ton of bricks i almost feel bad for the
guy almost but not quite you'll get them
next time pal up next we've got a guy
who proves that when it comes to leading
an adventurous life and having the best
party stories of all time size does not
matter get your mind out of the gutter
i'm talking about
scp-1867 lord blackwood don't judge this
book by its cover this little sea slug
defies expectations at every turn if you
believe a word that comes out of his
mouth that is i'll be honest a lot of
what's feeling funny about lord
blackwood is unintentional sorry my lord
but you kind of can't beat the feeling
of hearing a sea slug say hello or tell
you about the time he personally went
head to head with scp-682 on a hunting
expedition that's not to discount his
ability to be funny on purpose either if
you prefer sophisticated wit over
slapstick you can share some chuckles
with lord blackwood over a glass of his
finest whiskey can slugs have whiskey
well apparently this one can cat excuse
me i'm in the middle of something
fine okay geez you can have your turn
that very insistent voice calling to me
from offstage is none other than
dr spanko doctor of what exactly i'm not
sure the sapient male corn creek will
take your ear off if you let him
sometimes literally not that you'll be
able to understand a word he says unless
you're familiar with the particularly
silly dialect of english he seems to
speak say hello doctor it is me
make sure you keep your distance as this
bird's bark is also as bad as his bite
by which i mean his vocalizations are
extremely loud and can cause serious
damage to your ears if you're not
careful but what a way for your hearing
to go out listening to this weird little
bird talk shout or even yodel don't
think about heckling him either he might
scratch her eyes out just toss some
gummy worms up on the stage and no one
gets hurt speaking of getting hurt do
you like practical jokes how about
television how about mixing the two
together no need to answer because our
next guest is already here whether you
like it or not have you ever laughed
like you come laugh and have all the fun
and laugh starring all your favorite
laughs so ever and always may go to your
life
sorry i don't know what that was
something came over me all of a sudden
anyway here's scp-2030
everyone's favorite anomalous tv show
laugh is fun with your host laffy
mclafferson if you've never seen the
show before then well you're in for a
hell of a treat it's a hidden camera
comedy a bit like punk if you can
remember that one catching everyday
people in wild wacky situations like
meeting a talking dog being shoved
through a mail slot or having their hair
suddenly catch on fire it's a riot
seriously sometimes there's an actual
riot i watch someone get torn to pieces
[Laughter]
there's only one thing this show and its
mysterious faceless host want in the
world to make you laugh because why
laugh is fun don't look up the people
who appear on the show to find out what
happened to them after their appearance
though you might not like what you find
that took things on a bit of a dark note
there let's lighten it up with something
beautiful huh how about that does that
sound good to you guys i know it sounds
good to me great because here comes the
most beautiful person you've ever seen
scp-056 a beautiful person some critics
out there will say that a person can't
have both good looks and personality
that there's no way someone this
supernaturally gorgeous could also be
funny but they'd be wrong see this
anomalous individual changes to suit the
preference of their environment becoming
whatever would be superior to the person
they're currently with they've
transformed into a large beautiful
labrador in the presence of a dog a
woman looking like scarlett johansson
around a group of young female staff a
gorgeous and brilliant female doctor in
a white lab coat an impossibly strong
male bodybuilder a woman with cat ears
and a tail in the presence of one
researcher with an anime habit
a weeb and more so if you put them in a
comedy club they'll be the funniest one
in the room by default they can't help
it so if the hottest thing in the world
to you is a sense of humor get ready to
crack up but i hope you've got a thick
skin because
scp-056 has a really nasty attitude and
tends to prefer
insult comedy don't let it get you down
though they're that rude to everybody
it's hard to be the best at everything
in the world without your ego inflating
to the size of the empire state building
would you look at that we've got a
second celebrity guest in the room
tonight another performer you might
recognize from inside your tv i hope you
don't think clowns are scary because
it's time for scp-993
bobble the clown bobble the clown is the
star of his titular television show
which features him learning about all
different new skills of course if you're
over the age of 10 you might not have
seen the show at all since folks above
that age cut off become unconscious upon
viewing an episode so if you've missed
it i'll get you up to speed bottle
teaches all kinds of useful skills for
everyday life such as let me check my
notes here
cooking and preparing human flesh
lighting fires without drawing attention
from the police silently stalking
strangers through the streets extracting
information through torture and um
reaching scp containment i'm sorry this
appears to be some kind of mistake
security could i get security please can
you please get this clown out of here
i'm so sorry about that everyone great
comedy should push the envelope and bend
the rules but there are some lines that
just shouldn't be crossed like
cannibalism and breaking security
protocols if you forgive the
interruption we'll get on with the show
do i have anyone from boston in the
crowd tonight let me hear some noise for
boston do i have fish in the crowd
tonight put your fins together yeah
great great well you bostonites and fish
alike will love our next kooky character
coming to the mic it's one of dr
wondertainment's famous little misters
scp-527 mr fish love the top hat buddy
looking dapper looking good now if mr
fish doesn't do any tricks no breathing
underwater or anything flashy like that
he doesn't need to just being himself is
plenty hey what are you looking at you
think this is some kind of joke i'm just
a guy with a fish head okay do you know
any jokes though sure fine uh what do
you call fish with no ice i don't know
what do you call a fish with no eyes a
fish
take care everybody tip your waitress
i'm going home mr fish everybody great
guy great guy you'll be over the moon
for this next anomaly on our lineup he's
not crazy he's just a little bit spacey
i want you to give a warm interstellar
welcome to scp-1233
the lunatic this guy came a long way for
our show from outside the earth's
atmosphere in fact
scp-1233 is a humanoid entity resembling
a person in an emu-type spacesuit
complete with visor and propulsion
jetpack it's no ordinary suit either
it's resistant to explosions and x-ray
scans as well as being totally
bulletproof but what's funny about all
that you ask some say laughter is the
sound of surprise and this guy is
nothing if not surprising he arrives on
earth by falling out of the sky before
crashing into the ground like a
meteorite and immediately climbs up out
of the hole and starts looking for
volunteers to join him in the fight
against the moon monsters now the war is
no laughing matter but how can you keep
a straight face when he's mistaking a
cookie for a parakeet or trying to use a
dog to buy more dogs that's star quality
right there pun very much intended don't
even think about it though tomatoes i'm
in charge up here up next we have me i
mean me
me
me
for crying out loud i'm scp-426 and i'm
coming up to the stage i am an ordinary
toaster that does everything a toaster
is supposed to do mainly make bread into
toast but when a human being talks about
me they're unable to describe me in the
third person no matter how hard they try
they'll find themselves talking about me
in the first person instead if they're
around me for too long usually around
two months or more they'll begin to see
themselves as a toaster and try to plug
themselves into the wall and toast bread
not me
me i mean me i'm not a toaster i am stop
laughing this isn't funny get me out of
here not me
me toaster me
thank you
finally that was horrible i'm never
eating toast again okay that's a lie
i'll probably have a piece tomorrow
can't resist that crunch anyway up next
is the stuff of legends someone who's
been in the game for years and has the
most devoted following i've ever seen
put your tentacles together and give it
up for scp-2662
cthulhu he's a cognito hazardous entity
about 4 meters tall with 20 fully
functioning tentacles on his back talk
about multitasking cthulhu is a nice guy
no ego to speak of but he's got a bit of
an interesting effect on people let's
call him an acquired taste after someone
has been exposed to him for a prolonged
period of time around six months or
longer they'll become increasingly
compelled to do whatever he wants and
become a sort of servant so to get an
honest reaction he'll only practice his
stand-up material on people he's known
for less than six months i mentioned his
fan base before and i wasn't kidding
when i said they're devoted without
meaning or even wanting to
scp-2662 is able to spontaneously
generate religious followings about once
a month you can't pick your fans no
matter how hard you try and believe me
he's tried everybody wants to be a
celebrity until that fame comes with
strangers trying to break you out of
foundation containment and perform dark
arcane rituals with you poor guy he just
wants to be recognized for his sense of
humor rather than his incomprehensible
ancient powers and status as an elder
god you know what we haven't had much of
yet today animal acts that seems like a
real missed opportunity for those of us
who find nothing in the world funnier
than an animal doing something you
wouldn't normally see a monkey making a
phone call incredible who's he calling
the ceo of bananas or how about a cat in
a little business suit hilarious and
adorable well i hope you're not an
arachnophobe because next up we've got
scp-1006 the communist spiders these
little guys are incredibly impressive
consisting of an organized collective of
an unknown spider species all of whom
have somehow achieved sapience and
organized themselves into a tiny
functioning government they've used
their webs to spell out propaganda
messages and illustrate portraits of
people's faces as well as developing
simple tools when given alternate
methods of communication that don't come
out of their butts such as ink and
poster paper the spiders are happy to
make their thoughts known to humans
don't get too comfortable with them
they're not especially fond of what the
bourgeoisie humanoids have done with the
outside world politically active spiders
are pretty great conceptually but don't
let them hear you laughing if you get on
their bad side you might end up like the
skeletal human remains found in part of
their central web can we um get these
guys out of here actually their little
legs are giving me the creeps speaking
of creeps horror and comedy are often
two sides of the same coin both rely on
the subversion of expectations building
up tension before releasing it either
with screams or a bout of laughter just
look at horror comedy as a genre or
successful comedians who've pivoted into
the world of scares and shrieks or for
the opposite side look for some of the
horror movies that once terrified
audiences in the days before technicolor
absurd looking plastic skeletons
flopping around while an actress screams
unconvincingly and runs in slow motion
giant cardboard ants demolishing cities
sometimes something intended to be very
scary is actually just extremely funny
that brings us to scp-2006
too spooky when in its default state
scp-2006 is a spherical entity about 50
centimeters in diameter however it's
rarely in this shape for long all that
this thing wants in the world is to
scare humans and it will shift to
whatever shape it thinks will help it
accomplish that goal unfortunately for
scp-2006 and fortunately for humanity
its sense of what is scary is not
especially well-formed it tends to model
itself after characters from just the
type of b-movies i was talking about its
current favorite shape is that of the
titular villain from the 1953 film robot
monster it's a nice effort it really is
but when that big goofy gorilla suit
with a space helmet on top comes jumping
out at you it's one of the funniest
things i've ever seen do me a favor
though if it tries to scare you just
humor it will you just play along it's
the polite thing to do up next like many
of the people you see hitting up comedy
open mics this next guest has a day job
he won't be quitting anytime soon it's
scp-2598 the traveling moth salesman you
may have some trouble seeing him from
the audience but he's a large yellow
underwing moth wearing a tiny little
helmet he's able to communicate using
morris code so if you're not familiar
with it you'll need someone to translate
what he says for you no matter what
you're talking about
scp-2598 will always try to redirect the
conversation towards a specialized
helmet for moths also known as a moth
helm available for three easy payments
of 19.99 i'd tell you more about it but
unless they offer to sponsor the show i
don't think i should give them any more
free advertising wait a second my guest
is flying away hey hey where are you
going oh i see moth's got them off well
they're giving me the light so that's my
time everybody now i've got to get to my
next gig i'm hosting dr bright's annual
karaoke contest and i just know he's
going to do all of bohemian rhapsody
again so i'm going to get out of here
but first which scp do you think is the
funniest let us know in the comments
down below and maybe we'll give them
some more time in the spotlight next go
check out scp dating game and top 14
friendliest scps for more fun with scp
compilations